alright
welcome to the science institute my name
is prasad raghavenza i'm a senior
scientist at the institute
the institute is a collaborator
that was set up 10 years ago
with the generous grant from the simons
foundation
it hosts two
programs in theatrical computer science
and related areas every semester and
each program attracts about 70
researchers from all over the world
and most programs have three workshops
and a bootcamp
this one of the programs this semester
is the computational innovation and data
driven biology
thanks to the correct foundation for
support of this program
and welcome to the second workshop of
this program
uh computational challenges in very
large scale or mix
first i'd like to thank the organizers
roderick grigo
stephen brenner sandra and tudor talpko
for arranging an excellent set of
speakers for this week
before i hand over to roderick to
introduce the workshop in a moment
a couple of logistic things
snacks and coffees coffee breaks are
outside
and lunches are on your own
please enjoy the food and coffee outside
the auditorium
as food that they're not allowed inside
but the water is definitely fine
masks are strongly recommended but not
really require not required
uh lockers are
available on the first floor if you'd
like to use to use them to
store your luggage uh or bags during
lunch time now the wi-fi is of course
cal visitor in your room
our videographer is uh omid fur who will
assist with speakers with microphones
and computers right there
and finally a big thanks to kelani
pendleton who's right outside
our events coordinator for all her work
on local arrangements for this week feel
free to ask us or her any questions that
you might have during the course of the
workshop
without much
so i'm stephen brenner i'm faculty here
at berkeley and i'm joined by ron
schmier who is from tel aviv university
and we are the pis of the court berkeley
tel aviv initiative
which has sponsored the month-long
program that's here
of which this conference is a component
the the core of berkeley television
initiative and computational biology has
many activities um this has been one of
the premier ones to bring people
together from around the world to
discuss computational biology and
bioinformatics
we also have major activities in giving
grants
for groups jointly between berkeley and
tel aviv and there's been a lot of
exciting research that's come out of
those as well as workshops and other
exchange programs um and so we're really
grateful um to roderick and sandrine
especially for bringing together the
incredible set of speakers for this week
and i'll hand it over to ron anything
else you want to add
thank you steven so
we are finally doing it
thank you roderick for persisting we
tried it in 2020 we tried it again at
2021 and we are finally doing it in 2022
and
you know
over the last few months while planning
it
we were crossing our fingers to
make it happen and it's really great to
see everyone here
uh i should mention that this is part of
a summer program of the correct
berkeley tel aviv initiative and for
those
pis and students who are staying here
for the full summer program we are all
also organizing uh
short talks and reading groups
outside the
the conference weeks
and
you're all very welcome to participate i
think you will receive emails about this
the first conference that we had two
weeks ago was excellent and we are
looking forward to
another excellent conference now and
thanks sandrine and roderick for
leading this
thanks i have a little to add i just i'm
very happy to see to see all of you here
after all i started ron said after all
this year i actually checked today and i
i i realized that the first message that
i got from ron and stephen in batting
sandrine and myself was three years ago
in september
2019 so it has been really it has been
really a
a long a long long journey
so i'm actually happy that almost all of
of of you could make it we had at the
end to only two
two
issues with two people that couldn't
make it for because of of kobit
and i i apologize in in in their name
that says jas jasin who was almost on
the way to the airport and
and jasmine fisher
and
anyway i i believe that we still have
really a great workshop and i hope that
that that you that you really enjoy it
we had us
at the great first world shock organized
by robert and i hope that this will be
of equal interest and that you also
enjoy
the berkeley campus i can be here now
for two weeks i'm really enjoying the
first workshop and the recovery after
the first workshop
[Music]
let me just remind you that in addition
to the talks there will be a few
additional activities we have today a
final discussion
[Music]
which will be led by sandrine uh and
followed by a dinner for uh for speakers
uh
poster presenters and long-term
long-term
participants tomorrow we had a
poster present a poster and a reception
which actually will be attended by the
counselor of the university of berkeley
and on
wednesday we have a hike
i'm told that's really a beautiful
beautiful one so there's still a slots
available in in case you want you want
to to join us it's uh
about one and a half one or forty five
minutes hike
so that i think it's probably accessible
to to all of you
and i just want to finish by thanking
the people that can make this possible
of course all of you for being here
then the
something to dude actually she has been
really a great colleague and uh uh some
great help she put a lot of effort into
into organizing this and a lot of great
ideas in terms of participants and
activities
uh the
of course uh uh ron and stephen for
pursuing this overall this time and for
organizing this this series and
and uh the simon's institute i think
this is really a great place and uh in
particular to thank peter and kelani
because they're they are really really
very responsive of
our needs i do believe that lines today
is included although lunch
i'm confused about this but uh right so
in general lunch is on your own but i
think that today if i am not wrong lunch
is included because we have really short
lunch break today okay thanks a lot and
well actually i'm here because i'm going
to share the first
the first session and the first speaking
is hagen tilner here
which i don't have the tattoo with me
because it's there but i guess that
would sit here which is probably single
cell in the brain all right and long
read uh things like that
okay
i can uh uh i think that we have uh
how much 20 minutes 30 minutes
so if i was 30 with questions yeah
started with questions so
when you have 20 minutes i'll try to
wait with me
okay great um yeah first thank you for
having me here today i'm really honored
to to be part of this
and i like to start my talks we're
showing this cover which is was actually
made when i was a phd student in
rutlek's lab 2012.
um
it was for encode and it showed many
things so the cover actually goes on
these things here and here and here but
what was most important to to me and to
my work at the time was um
this connection basically between the
dna
the rna and the timing of splicing with
respect to where the polymerase is what
you see here is all these exons and
these rocket shaped things here
and then the introns in between are
mostly already gone so uh um while two
still remains so we basically said most
of uh interns are removed code
transcription
um yeah we're based here in manhattan um
this is where the um
where the school is this is where where
postdocs are housed and yeah we're
always looking for good people so one
more introduction about splicing so
splicing is basically the gibberish that
the um the process that takes the
gibberish is pre-messenger rna decides
where exons are removes the entrance in
between so that we get a final message
it was night in october you can all
understand that phrase
with just a little bit of alternative
splicing we can turn we can get a second
exon here and get a second message okay
it was nine in the long term october
not very very different from the first
message but now there's a connotation
because the second one is coming out of
a poem by elgar and paul
okay so that's one way to think about
alternative splicing so the slight
modulation of um
of a message
with a connotation of somewhat
something that's something different
now
there are other ways to think about it
as well if you consider this phrase here
monday i have facts with just a little
bit more of alternative splicing i can
turn that into monday i have alternative
facts
phrase made famous by kellyanne conway
and of course whenever you've
seen that interview you know that this
means pretty much the opposite of the
first
right and that is not just happening in
this toy example that actually happens
in biology quite a bit so there's work
coming out of harvard this is mark
riedel's lab
where they basically asked how different
are two protein isoforms encoded by the
same gene one being here so this is a
dissimilarity one being totally
different zero being the same
and here they they frame this in in
um in protein protein interactions so
when you add one the two isoforms don't
have any similarity in the proteins they
interact with when you're at zero you
have the same when you see that for
about 20
you get pretty much the opposite so
basically no protein protein interaction
partners in common then for another 45
to 50 you get quite some differences and
then you get less and less and maybe for
16 17 18 you get no differences at all
and i would argue that this is probably
a lower bound because this is obviously
done in some condition and you know the
the conditions that we uh that we could
potentially explore are infinite or
almost infinite and um
and of course protein protein
interaction is also not the only thing
so um i started my lab you know six
years ago in new york city and as part
of the
neuroscience institute so we really
wanted to work on this beast here and in
reality that means we worked a lot on
this bc and now we're actually starting
to work this year and so the important
point is that whenever you measure
proteins rna expression splicing dna
methylation or many other traits
fundamentally what you're measuring is
sort of a linear combination of signals
coming from
from neurons from pendulum cells
oligodendrocytes astrocytes microglia
they forgot endothelial cells and of
course these have more subtypes so what
we really wanted to do is uh to untangle
this linear combination for splicing
work and for for gene expression a lot
had already been done right so the the
whole single cell approach i think most
people know that um was already out and
so we were basically sitting on top of
this approach and created something
called single cell ice from rna
sequencing scissors
and this was uh led by sean gupta and
paul collier but with contributions by
many so
look at the offer list there were people
all over the world helping and so
fundamentally what we did is we sit on
top of this um single cell world where
we basically do the single cell short
approach
to get this table that basically
connects individual cells or barcodes to
cell types and here's a graphic
representation of that um what we do
then is we do long read sequencing on
these full-length cdmas
locate the barcodes at the end and the
emis and so on and according to those
barcodes we will say that this molecule
originates from this individual cell now
this cell according to this table was
already placed in a
cluster of cells that we already labeled
as microglia according to market gene
expression therefore we can say that
this is a microglial re
um
and likewise for the second one we will
go to neurons and would
find that this read is now a purkinje
cell read
for kingdom cells so in the cerebellum
part of a very important part of the
brain more the ancient part of the brain
and these cells by the way are
very famous because they have these very
big arbors
um so the first thing when we started
this um this was somewhere in 2017 and
we asked ourselves do we actually do
well with recognizing these bar codes so
we took these barcodes that we knew to
exist from the illumina sequencing
learned an error profile or with pacbio
and nanopore and this is here the
biodata
introduced these errors and asked how
often do we actually get
the right barcode it turned out that the
specificity was basically 100
of course
when you simulate things you put a lot
of assumptions in right you you simulate
what you think is actually happening
there and so to test that that this was
not some sort of uh you know imperfect
assumptions that we were making we also
um
synthesized c c dna put a fixed barcode
in it put it so which is one of these
barcodes one that occurred very often
um put it on a sequencer so we know
exactly what the the answer is supposed
to be
asked the same question and found again
99.99 so in terms of specificity we did
really well i don't have the slide here
and sensitivity we were
not doing so great and um
yeah we have some ways now to to get it
better and then with these um um with
these weeds we can now make these plots
here where every line is one molecule
all these lines has been have been
grouped because they originate from the
same cluster of
cells
and here in blue we have neuronal
clusters so and these are the purkinje
cells um and then we have astrocytes
microglia and opecs
what you can see is that neurons are
characterized by the inclusion of the
first exon the second return of exon the
third the fourth
the fifth or the skipping of it and then
the six so there are two ice forms uh
really characterizing the neuron types
um
and you don't see these two ice forms
for example microglia also not in
astrocytes i think one of them you
observe once in all pieces so what that
means is that there is
cell type specificity in the isom
expression that is not there at the same
level in gene expression because
um this gene is expressed to some extent
in all of these
cell types
okay so when we had this
um technology working in the
in somewhere in 2019 we started asking
questions about uh
that we thought were
relevant to biological questions so here
we started with brain region specificity
so this is was led by a student anishka
glitter who's now close to graduating
but again there were many others
contributing to that
and so what she did is she said well
if we have pfc and hippocampus and from
either pseudo bulk or real bulk
experiments we know that there's
differences in isometric expression
between the two
what kind of cell types actually account
for that
and so there could be one cell type what
could be
inhibitory neurons in the in the
hippocampus spikes one way and
neurotransm in the pfc splice another
way
it could be many cell types so the brain
region could override cell type
specificity
and it could be no cell type at all
because due to the abundance and
possibly gene expression changes we
could get a very differently weighted
linear combination of signals in the two
brain regions and therefore it gets a uh
get an apparent difference which doesn't
exist in any cell type
okay so i'm just going to show you some
examples here this hippocampal
excitatory neurons you see that this
exon is highly included somewhere 1995
percent
in hippocampal astrocytes it's included
maybe 50 percent and they will come to
opc's
maybe 80
and then you go to the same three cell
types in the pfc
and it's mostly skipped there's a bit of
intron retention that could potentially
give rise to the inclusion of that exon
but it's much less than you see
up here
now so that means in this case really
the brain region overrides cell type
specificity
and we do see that more often than you
would expect by chance but what's
important to recognize it's still
a minority of cases okay so it's very
few but more than you would expect per
chance the majority actually follows
this model where you have a relatively
similar inclusion of the axon in
hippocampal astrocytes and pfc
astrocytes
likewise similar inclusion in opcs in
the two brain regions and then you go to
excitatory unions and you go from 81 to
23
okay so that is really the majority of
cases where you have uh one cell type
explaining it and of course now we could
um play the same game at finer cell
types again um yeah in this data set we
did not
good so and also in this paper we um we
developed something called slicer seek
for slice sliders from sequencing or
spatialized form sequencing um and
basically this was based on the 10x
technology again vision um but could in
principle be done with any
spatial especially barcoded cdns so here
the barcodes are used not to
delineate a single cell but a um an area
in the brain so every circle here gets
one barcode and the whole thing is more
or less like three thousand separate
sequencing experiments and we basically
uh developed the long read approach for
it
and so here's an example clef renee a
yellow means very high inclusion of this
exon black means skipping and you see a
lot of inclusion here in the hippocampus
and then skipping in the correct plexus
and the interesting point here is that
it correlates very nicely with the um
with the
with
leaving one structure and entering
another structure and the second axon is
mostly skipped but there is inclusion
only in the hippocampus not so much in
the correct plexus
so this is an example that actually um
sort of goes against what i just said
because here we have some snap 25a again
one exon here we don't have this precise
correlation with um with uh brain
structure so we have a lot of skipping
in this area
and as we slowly go towards the
hippocampus and the cortex and so on we
get higher and higher inclusion but it's
not really at the boundary of one
structure to another
and these are mutually exclusive exons
so the the other accent that's really
the opposite
so and currently we're involved in the
brain initiative and doing a lot of uh
work there where we're basically going
across brain regions and developmental
time points um and yeah but this is not
for today
so as i told you early on that really we
wanted to work on the human brain and
then did a lot of work on the mouse
brain
and fundamentally the reason for that
was that in the mouse brain since you
have fresh brain you can isolate single
cells
in frozen brain which is pretty much
any human brain you can use for research
purposes
you you cannot follow that approach
because things are frozen and you cannot
isolate single cells anymore
hence people use single nuclei
sequencing which for gene expression
works just fine for us it's a big
problem because in in nuclei you have a
lot of retained introns and a lot of rna
species that don't exist in the cytosol
so it took us a long time to get this
working and we call this uh approaching
our single nuclear ice from rna
sequencing it was led by simon hardwick
when who and undergraduate but again
many others
contributed to it
and so fundamentally
if you are uh doing single-cell
long-range stuff
if this is your gene this is the kind of
molecule you would like to have okay you
have sort of a
pcr adapter here then you have your 10x
barcode your umi polydt slash poly a
sequence depending on which strand you
actually sequenced then you have all the
exons and then you have a template
switch oligo which is made to
which is used to make the second strand
and then those two are also used for pcr
so unfortunately there's a lot of these
molecules they have all the nice barcode
structure
but they start in an intron they give
you 2kb of intronic sequence and then
they give you the template switch audio
so that is very nice for things like rna
velocity a technique that some people
here may know
for us it's a big problem because these
things don't tell us anything about
exome combinations or the inclusion of
certain exons
and then there's a third type of
molecule which is probably not um very
well known because in the illumina
protocol you heavily bias against it
that means even if they're produced
on illumina you won't see them but for
us when we put it on pacquiao or
nanopore then we end up with all these
molecules here and they basically
originate when the t is all instead of
making the um the second strand starts
to make a first strand right then you
end up with a molecule that has tso on
both ends and so basically we devise
technologies to to get rid of um or not
get rid of but to bias heavily against
these last two ones so that we get
mostly the first one the first is that
we basically start doing a linear pcr
from this black element because the
black element is always there when the
barcodes are there um
and that means we make a lot of single
strand molecules that represent this and
this
but not
this molecule so it means in in this
cartoon uh we put it as if this one
disappears that's not quite true it does
not disappear but it's not amplified
whereas these two are
then we use exon probes that hybridize
two exons to select for molecules that
have um
at least some exotic sequence okay and
again in this cartoonish version then
this molecule disappears of course it
doesn't disappear one hundred percent um
but we get a much cleaner uh much more
of these desired molecules and then
those we then put on the
longer sequences
and so this is was done in human frontal
cortex here you see all the um all the
cell types that you would expect
astrocytes microglia excitatory neurons
some inhibitory neuron types
oligodendrocytes and so on
and so what we observe is that in terms
of barcode efficiency we get a 2.2 fold
increase um and in terms of having uh um
reads that actually overlap annotated
exons you get the three point three-fold
increase so together it makes a seven
point five-fold experiment they increase
so that means an experiment that would
have cost thirty thousand dollars now
costs four thousand dollars
um
and so this is what we get then um so we
get quite often reads with one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten and
maybe some more exons um you see it's
not quite perfect because for some
reason we don't make it quite to the
first axon but we make it quite a long
way
um
and
what you see here is that we have
basically some actions that are really
highly included in astrocytes and a
little bit of norego dendrocytes not at
all in
in the neural types
um it turns out that one of these axons
i believe it's that one maybe it's that
one i don't know is um is associated to
autism spectrum disorder so we looked a
little bit into uh into diseases but
just to be clear this data all came from
healthy brains um so the first thing is
that we
looked at exons that were highly
variable so that uh when we look at the
inclusion percentage
that is the lowest among all the cell
types and the highest we had some exons
that have you know a change of at least
75 percentage points
and these are these blue ones here and
they're very short on on average they
peak at about 54 so it's not only
microaxons
although they include a lot of the uh
the micronesians and then um
the less variable types are actually
having quite longer distributions with
medians or or with peaks above 100 bases
and yeah there's work in this area by
the blanco gastronomy and hunting labs
so you should probably also read that
when we then looked at the
at exons that were associated to
different diseases for the autism ones
they were really very highly variable so
exons associated to autism much more
variable across cell types than the ones
not associated to autism in als there
was a hint of that and in schizophrenia
we did not see it there's one caveat
that
you know
these exon lists come from different
papers
and so the methods to define them are
not exactly identical so um
yeah we're still looking to this
somewhat but now
we these are autism associated
excellence and now we have basically
this heat map again we can see that the
this axon here highly included in the in
the neuron types not so much in the glia
then you have the ones that are highly
included overall
lowly included overall and um
and here the ones that are only in the
glia and now in disease that raises very
interesting questions because when an
axon is decreased in the in inclusion in
the bulb
in these exons it could come from pretty
much any cell type or maybe all cell
types together and these it would stand
to reason that it would come here from
the excitatory or inhibitory neurons um
and these ones from the glia
so that means there's no for some axons
it's actually very clear if there's
strong decrease in disease then for this
axon it must come from inhibitory
neurons
but for these ones it could come from
pretty much anyone
okay so now i want to talk a little bit
about the combinatorial patterns of all
these elements
exons tss and polyacids
so
here if you forget for a moment all the
cell types that are being shown here
what you what you observe is a lot of
molecules that have both axons included
and a lot of molecules that have both
skipped and then once in a while you may
find somewhere here some molecules that
have uh just infrastructure second so it
means it's strongly biased towards the
both inclusion or both skipping that's
what we call coordination and i will uh
use that word uh from now on in the talk
and so we basically looked at this um
the coordination of exons tss and
polycytes in specific cell types
um here just another example um
this map t so microtubule associated
protein tau very important in pretty
much all the neurodegenerative diseases
a lot of skipping of both
inclusion of the first
but skipping of the second
skipping of the first inclusion of the
second but not inclusion of both so
they're mutually exclusive which is also
a type of coordination
and here in this example again you have
two chord if you look at the pseudobulk
you have two nicely coordinated exons
however when you look at them in cell
types you can't really say that they're
coordinated anymore because here the
this axon is not even alternative so
that means this in this case
the um coordination
of the two axons is explained by a
constitutive use of at least one
almost both axons in the neurons
and pretty much constitutive skipping
and all the glia
and so this is what we try to highlight
in this heat map here so we started with
exon pairs that were coordinated and the
pinkish color tells you that in this
cell type
we can prove coordination what i want
you to observe is that for these exon
pairs here
pretty much in every row you see some
pink color
maybe the last 10 percent you don't but
that means in the vast majority of cases
we can actually um
we can actually um
uh trace this coordination into the cell
types when we do this for tss uh exon
pairs or example a side pairs we cannot
and this
greenish color here means that one of
the elements has become constituted
okay
um two more slides um
so
we basically started thinking recently
to really understand
in detail um
the error patterns of pac bio and omt
and so the question that we asked here
is if you put the same molecule on pac
bio and uh and nano pol
would the two agree or not and so this
was done you can't really put the same
molecule but you can use barcoding
techniques
and then have basically cdna copies of
the same rna molecule put them on both
part bio and nanopore and see where they
disagree and
and what we observe is that
a tss there's 80 agreement but there's
eight percent where only the pack bio
has a tss and now four is not um and
there's an about three percent where
they um um
uh where they have different tss now the
last
part here is
if this is the annotation and you have
this kind of molecule or this kind of
read coming out of the nanopore with an
acceptor that is three bases shifted up
now we can use we can ask on the same
molecule on the pac bio
what does the pack buyer actually say in
this case it confirms it pretty much all
the time it's a pretty rare event here
but those
upstream nag shifts we basically believe
if we do this for donors that have
shifted by four bears base pairs
it's basically never so basically one in
a thousand where this is actually
correct so
and basically we've exploited all these
um
all these error patterns now to to build
an annotation pipeline that we call
isoquant which in our opinion does
really really well for for novelized
forms for meaning that are not in the
annotation
for no nicer forms and
it does also well but there are also
other programs that do well
um
yeah and i guess i'll skip the remaining
sites and go for questions
and let me just put up the thank you
slide so thank you for
for listening this is the group the
people that do all the magic former
members the collaborators at weil
cornell and the funding sources
yeah and here are the conclusions
i won't go through them but
that was very very fascinating i was
wondering to what extent in the current
analysis you're conducting is the
decoding of the barcodes the bottleneck
i mean you mentioned the error you know
patterns at the end comparing ont and
pac-bio because you know the 10x pack
was designed for long read high error
rates is that's a limiting factor and do
you need related to this the short read
data still to match those or could you
do just the noble long read uh
sequencing maybe thinking about your
last few slides where you compare
technologies so the two questions um the
first one so on the pack bio it's not so
much the bottleneck anymore um
because um
um yeah the the error rate on the fact
bio now if you have ccs you know the
circular consensus which is really low
so it's really not a problem anymore on
the nanopore
we get much less
barcodes or high confidence barcodes so
it is to some extent and so from what
i've seen
like you know you can
increase recall quite significantly
but
and maybe even in a way that you are
that you decrease precision only
slightly but in my opinion if let's say
if your precision drops below 90 percent
it's already a very very bad
run because that would mean 10 of your
molecules would have been assigned to
wrong cell cells at least possibly to
wrong cell types
um
there was one question what was the
other one
oh so we do it with a short read data um
usually because this is sort of the
minor cost in the experiment
technically you wouldn't need it if you
have enough high quality reads right
because you could do it in principle
along with you can chunk them up to a
fake illuminate and then do exactly what
you uh what you did before um what
actually turned out for us to be a major
bottleneck which took us basically a
year and a half to solve is this problem
of these
these molecules that have tears also on
both ends which basically have no
barcodes because that turns out to be a
huge drive of the cost and uh yeah now
now we're much better with that um
yeah i think so
probably if let's say if pacquiao has a
major increase in throughput there will
be days then that then on the pacpayer
you would do this without illumina
sequencing
um on the nanopore i mean they already
have very high um throughput and you
know there's just a new um kit out now
for the uh for the r10 flow cell
it's possible that we'll reach that soon
technically you can do it now it's just
more expensive basically
so
you have been showing how you could use
isoforms to identify particular cell
types
so my question is uh
what will be the relative contribution
of specific isoforms to neural cell type
identity versus expression of different
genes and
you know whether you could use these
information for the convolution
approaches and so forth
i mean theoretically you can
right now it's a bit difficult to answer
because usually we don't have the same
depth per single cell um
um
as the the short-range approach and so
um in for gene expression also beauty is
that you know if one gene gives you no
molecules that's actually information
right that's
you can use that for clustering if for
splicing if the gene gives you no
molecules it's
it's basically n a it's not zero right
so
so i'm not yet 100 sure what the answer
to that is um
i hope we'll get there
i have a question regarding the last
part you didn't talk about the isoquant
so what specific technicalities did you
consider to infer isoforms from the
laundry data and did you do that
separately for differently for pac-pile
and nanopore
yeah so um actually um
so we have a couple slides about this so
there is what it is basically it's a
graph that represents um introns and
basically you have a
edge between two entrants if they're
adjacent right and then it uses a lot of
techniques out of uh out of graph theory
and it comes out of the genome assembly
field um that
you know bulge removal for example seems
to be very important but also what i
mentioned previously that you know the
splice set that we do some spy site
correction where we say well look we've
learned already that this kind of
mapping is not to be trusted and then
there are other ones that are not in the
previous paper where you basically look
very
carefully at these alignments and ask
whether we should trust them or not okay
thank you
thanks i i have a more exotic question
and also forgive me if it's not you
i've been out of this area for for some
years but i mean um you didn't mention
uh the different types of spliceosomes i
mean you won youtube versus your new
does that have any um i mean also there
are some genes where you mix the two
types of introns uh
is that something you can study here or
well theoretically you can then the
problem in a sense is that um
something like i think 98.5 of interns
are you two and then one percent is u12
but out of those one percent two thirds
are still gtag
so fundamentally
you know your observations will always
be dominated by um by uh by the u2 or
the let's say the gtag consensus right
and
so we haven't really dug deep into it
the code actually checks we only believe
reads when every read is consensus which
means gtag gcag or atac which includes
the u12
we haven't really ever made a statement
about the u12 once because my feeling
and you please correct me on that is
that in a sense
u12 is super important for some genes
and then for many it's not that means
unless you are really into this gene
right it uh it may not be a so it's it
doesn't lend itself to make genome-wide
statements very easily right
but it could be yeah it's if if the
mapper does the mapping right then
there's no problem with it so the same
question for for uti and trunks anything
that is special
with them or because you didn't
mention them so utr insurance um we
haven't specifically looked at them i
mean they would be in the mappings um in
the papers we published we did not look
at them we should actually um
um i mean
what i would say is that probably in the
three prime less because of nonsense
mediated decay
and five premiere there's upstream open
reading frames i know we've actually
discussed that but in the end nobody
really uh mapped these uh
these um special five prime um utr
things so that we could actually check
them against introns but i would assume
that there must be something also that
you know some kozak sequences some start
components that are affected by introns
now how wide spread
i don't know but i'm sure many uh
[Music]
there must be a lot of work out there
not maybe not about brain cell types i
don't
know all right
all right wonderful talk and excuse me
if this is a naive question but um how
do you distinguish tissue specificity
and isoform expression versus
um temporal differences say due to
chronology or you know chronicity rather
how do you know are you looking at a
snapshot in time do you look across
different
times yeah so in this data we haven't
now what we're doing in the brain
initiative is exactly that to do
developmental time courses where mice
are being interrogated at multiple time
points um so
i hope this data will inform us on
exactly that and so
we are playing a lot with what we call
these hypervariable axons that really
change
dramatically um and um
you know it's actually quite interesting
because there's different patterns some
really go up in time so yeah you throw
it into your neurons and then over time
they come up some peak early and come
down again so what you're presenting is
kind of a snap a snapshot they're all
controlled at a certain
age so what i showed you today
what i showed you today in mice was once
at p1 one day after birth the cerebellum
and then p7 i didn't say that um
so seven days after birth that was the
two brain regions
now in the brain initiative it's
multiple time points that uh basically
describe the um so we really don't know
well we have some data i haven't shown
anything here but yeah we have some data
that actually shows
many many actions that that do these
things
they give you basically certain groups
but everything i showed you today is a
snapshot do you suspect something like
an editing mechanism and cephalopods or
you know that you see in cephalopods you
think there's a lot of variability in
this and
well i mean it's already established by
by many other people before us that
there is developmental regulation
splicing in uh
many people for focused on neurons but
also glia there are some
some things known so yeah
yes another question here daddy
i was interested in your result that the
autism genetic risk
was enriched in the
variable exons or the genes of variable
exons um and the reason i was is we've
been studying the non-coding risk for
different psychiatric diseases and see
there a lot of cell type specificity as
well
um my question is
um do you think that that is because the
risk is in cell types that themselves
just in general have more exon skipping
or variability in the isoforms
um
or
does your result hold for each cell like
if you look at it cell type by cell type
see the trend consistently across all
types or is it sort of specific
it wasn't i mean what i was expecting
actually when we did this is that that
the autism actions would all be highly
included in the neurons and not in the
glia and there were certainly a lot of
these but there are also some that do
the opposite um so
yeah
yeah we're seeing the non-coding risk in
the glia also yeah so i think that
it doesn't seem like there's sort of
one cell type where that is pinpointed
by here everything goes wrong
um yeah but we haven't done the the
cases yet but um
[Music]
i would guess that it actually
you know that there's
multiple axons that that go wrong in
just one cell type or just in glia and
then many that go just in neurons and
then maybe that some that go wrong all
over the place
that's my guess but cool
thank you it's a great discussion but we
need to move to our next speaker